hey welcome to the gq recommends show
this is a show where we break down all
of the essential clothes that you should
own
[Music]
these are the shoes that will cover you
in any situation if you have these five
pairs of shoes in your arsenal you are
set
the casual lace-up
[Music]
basically if you look in the dictionary
under shoe this is the shoe you're going
to see it is a very basic
beautiful shoe that goes with absolutely
everything you can definitely dress them
up you can dress them down i think it's
like the new age dress shoe if you were
only gonna own one pair of shoes that
would be a mistake but this would be the
pair of shoes you could get away with
i think the doc martin oxford is like
amazing it's kind of like another
wardrobe staple that you should have doc
martens were originally a working-class
shoe they were made to be worn in
factories they look really great scuffed
up and they come in like a range of
really great colors the style itself is
like evolved through time but like the
classic one is like the black
i also love the clarks wallaby it's an
all-time classic beloved by the wu-tang
clan it has this really cool
weird oblong shape to it that's not
quite squared toe it's not quite rounded
you could wear these with like jeans you
could wear them with shorts i've seen
people like wear them with a suit
probably like in a darker colorway not
really this like lighter version but i
definitely think it's important to like
show off this type of shoes because
they're so classic they are also super
accessible doc martens for instance and
clark's they're going to clock in way
under 200 and you're going to be able to
wear them all the time they're gonna
last you for ages if you want to step
things up a little bit you could also
try getting a pair of shoes from a brand
like paraboot which is a french company
they hand make all of their shoes in
france and they are very hardy and
beautiful and they will last you a
lifetime timberland also makes these
classic lug sole trail moccasins they
have sort of a boat shoe look about them
but they're not as preppy as the ones
that your dad used to wear they are
another very great option if you're
looking for something a little bit more
rugged to add to your wardrobe so we see
tyler the creator with these like cool
wallaby-esque style shoes and like a
bubble gum pink and like this like light
blue which is great and then when he's
wearing the darker color he's wearing
them with like
a white sock which is great kind of
draws attention to it and he's wearing
them with like a dress pant which is
nice so it's like something a little bit
more dressed up but still feels like
casual enough to like run around and not
feel stuffy these shoes are as versatile
as it gets and that's why they're the
number one category on our list the
classic sneaker
[Music]
i describe this category as your
everyday perfect type of shoe that you
can grab on the go it's always with you
it goes with everything but we're not
talking about the hype sneakers we're
not talking about the one-offs the rare
grails we're talking about just the
classic sneakers they've been around the
block also a good thing is that all
these classic sneakers are pretty
affordable this is a pair of adidas
sambas classic sort of soccer sneakers
they're super comfortable and they come
in a lot of different colors a lot of
like celebrities out there wearing these
too
i mean we all know about the air force
one it's like the perfect white
basketball kind of sneaker you can see
like milluma and jeremy o'harris wearing
them they kind of just add like a cool
flair to any outfit this is like a new
york
staple it's like a bacon egg and cheese
for your feet i think the key about
classic sneakers is really sticking to
like a classic colorway which is like
white black and gray and then let like
mother nature like make it a different
color you know like dirtying it up a lot
of sneakers historically come from
sports this pair right here converse was
one of the original basketball shoes so
it's been around the block now it's just
one of those classic things that is
ready for pretty much any outfit
my go-to classic sneaker is a white
chuck taylor all-star i like them really
beat up i only do the high tops not the
low tops
you know i've sort of come around to the
low tops i've seen it done
really cool with really baggy pants not
necessarily a lot of like ankle showing
so i mean joaquin phoenix is like a
legend he wears converse all the time
that's his go-to you can see he's
wearing it with like a tuxedo which is
kind of great and it just gives your own
like personal style and edge to your
look you can really make them your own
you can like change the laces as we see
you see people like write on them to
give them a bit more personality that's
the great thing about this category is
you can't do any wrong
boots
[Music]
everybody loves boots and you need at
least a couple of pairs in your life
you're gonna need a pair of all-weather
boots boots that can survive a blizzard
that can help you walk through a
rainstorm and then you're gonna need a
pair of sort of anytime boots it's not
as formal as a dress shoe but it's not
like you're just kicking it with a pair
of sneakers whatever
one of our absolute favorite all-weather
boots here at gq is the blunstone it
comes from australia it is built for
farming and trudging through the muck
and it is built to stand up to pretty
much anything it's got this very
nice sturdy rubber sole it's got a very
easy slip-on slip-off design
if you wear them into the ground like i
have with mine they are going to come
out looking
pretty cool in my opinion you can wear
this pretty much all year long it's not
too heavy but it's still very warm in
the winter time these are an everyday
shoe for a lot of people and with good
reason
[Music]
these were originally made in the 70s
it's a timeless style and if you know
you are about to see some [ __ ] this will
get you through it boots can be a little
bit pricier but it's worth spending a
little bit more on them this pair for
instance from danner will run you close
to 400
but think of it like winter tires for
your feet they're the boots that you
need to make winter a little bit more
tolerable if you want something just as
weather friendly at a lower price point
timberland makes a great pair of boots
that can withstand any rain or snow
on the complete opposite end of the
spectrum from the boots we've just been
talking about are these very very slick
chelsea boots from saint laurent they
are closer to a dress shoe than they are
to a winter boot they are elongated and
elegant and they're made from a really
fine leather you know they have a bit of
a rockstar edge to them these are the
creme de la creme but you don't have to
drop a grand to get this look there's a
whole world of chelsea boots out there
for you to explore you can grab them
from a brand like grensen maybe which
makes really nice made in england boots
jonah hill here is wearing his chelsea
boots with a pretty wild shirt and some
beat to hell jeans the boots really help
to tie this together you know he could
look like that crazy hippie guy that you
run into on the beach that offers you
weed and he sort of still does but you
can tell that he has his stuff together
a little bit more because of those boots
the loafer
[Music]
these are the untouchable outfit
elevating slip-ons they are having a
serious moment and there are a ton of
different styles of these there's
absolutely gonna be one that fits your
style the loafer
is maybe my favorite category really
elevates
any outfit maybe my favorite part is
that there are no laces to deal with
great you can slip them on without socks
you can throw them on with a thick pair
of white socks you can wear them with
dress socks it kind of goes with
whatever your vibe is this is probably
the most iconic and classic version of a
loafer it's a penny loafer and these
ones specifically made by g.h bassinko
or like the definitive penny loafer bass
was one of the
first companies to
bring this style to america and make it
popular miles davis wore these shoes jfk
wore these shoes paul newman pulled
these off they are an incredible shoe
with a lot of history they are super
affordable and super versatile and they
come in a huge range of colors i love
you know this classic oxblood looks
really great with a lot of different
things if you sort of want to
step up your loafer game and you have a
little bit of a larger budget this pair
from vinnie's is a great option they are
in a really beautiful suede that's going
to pop and give a really luxurious edge
to all of your outfits
the be-all and end-all of luxury loafers
is the gucci loafer this is their
classic horse bit loafer it clocks in
well over eight hundred dollars but it's
worth it because they're gucci a lot of
the times loafers will have some kind of
like ornamentation like this this right
here is
kind of as classic as as you can get
other than like a penny loafer you're
not going to regret an investment like
this these are always going to look
as luxurious and as elevated as possible
the pair that i have on now is
my most recent
obsession says pair
from a brand called 80s still got the
classic sort of penny loafer style but
with this croc embossing here and i like
that the toe is kind of square almost
like a birkenstock if you are looking to
go a little crazy with your loafers you
could try out a pair of belgian slippers
like these
they have a much more exaggerated and
crazy cut to them which shows off a
little bit more of your socks or your
foot and they come in all sorts of crazy
colors like this beautiful green that i
picked out a shoe like this might look a
little bit more intimidating to some but
honestly the trick to pulling any shoe
off is to just kind of do it without
much of a care in the world this is a
very formal
type of loafer but that makes it all the
cooler when you pull it off with a
casual look as well if you're having
trouble
figuring out how to wear some loafers
just google tyler the creator style and
you're probably on a good path
the dress shoe
[Music]
they're a bunch of different kinds but
we've just narrowed it down to a few
that are just classic will go well for
most fancier occasions the first pair
that we've got here is a pair from
churches pretty long established
shoemaker based in england this
particular style here is what's called a
cap toe it's pretty plain which means
that it's easy to go with a lot of
outfits they're also another shoe that
you can dress up and dress down i don't
necessarily think you need to be like
going to like a business meeting to wear
a dress shoe even if you want to just go
on a pair of jeans and like address you
to like go to the office it kind of just
elevates your look this is another cap
toe shoe in a really nice mid brown if
you are not so keen on a black dress
shoe a mid brown a slightly dark brown
dress shoe like this is
really easy to pair
with most outfits i would say if this is
going to be your first dress shoe you
probably want to go with something like
this the dress shoe is like more of an
investment piece i think they can range
from like around 300 to like these
churches are probably like in the 900s
but they're something you'll have
forever and if you take care of them
they'll last you a lifetime they all
have their
little like adornments a sort of like
rule of thumb is that the less stuff the
dressier it is so if you're looking for
something to wear with a tuxedo like a
really shiny sort of like patent leather
type situation without anything on it
you will do fine you look great if
you're looking for a pair of classic
black dress shoes that are going to go
with everything but you don't want to
break the bank this pair of allen
edmonds park avenue
cap-toe shoes are a really good bet if
you need a pair of dress shoes but don't
want to spend all that much there are
plenty of options out there this british
brand solo bear or even
doc martens has some dressier options
for more casual look i'd wear the dress
shoe with like a jean or like a chino
and like an oversized like concert tee
you could do like jay-z and just do like
a t-shirt under your suit this just kind
of shows you don't have to go full-on
dressy with a dress shoe david beckham's
like a style god he definitely made this
dress shoe like look and feel a bit more
casual but still elevated he has them in
like a cognac color which is great it's
like something different from like your
traditional black or like your dark
brown so
this is my go-to pair right now of dress
shoes they're a little weird i found
them vintage and then i had a guy
resold them
with this like crazy
sole i don't really wear this with a
suit i more so often wear this like with
some big old jeans this is an example of
something that would be a dress shoe but
i
wear it wherever shakira whenever
wherever if you get a good pair you can
have them resold have them for years and
years and years and pass them on
thanks for watching if you like any of
these shoes we've included links in the
description below for you to cop them
right now